being that i'm always right one of my
great talents is offering advice
the problem is that people don't ask me
for advice so that leaves me to
offer the advice unsolicited and they
call this mansplaining i think is that
that's that's technically what that's
called so
today instead i've decided that i'd like
to do a little uh advice segment
i'm gonna pilfer questions from another
advice column
and i'll i'll give you the real advice
the correct answers to those um
questions and for those purposes today
we're gonna we're gonna refer to slate
now slate has what it looks like are a
couple of different advice columns to
on that are up on their website they
have all kinds of poor saps that
come to them asking for help um and i
thought this was especially important
because
the advice they get is is terrible the
advice that's dispensed is often even
more misguided than the original
question so that everybody at the end of
it is just even more confused so today
we're going to go through
take some of these questions and then
give the real answers to those questions
all right oh and also before we get
going i have been
told that i need to tell you to where
does it ring the bell for the
just for to subscribe i think is the
reason for doing that
all right and now from slate let's start
here here's a question uh sent in by
someone who identifies himself as
confused cuck that's his that's his name
he's giving himself i didn't give him
that name
he says my wife and i live in the small
conservative rural town
that we both were raised in after having
been married for about 12 years my wife
and i began
the hot wife lifestyle
and have been hot wifing about five
years now
no idea what that means but i think
we're gonna find out it was my
idea and she was initially resistant to
it but eventually she said yes i find it
an incredible turn on and honestly she
has enjoyed it more than she ever
imagined
there have been different men over those
years some of them longer term and some
not
my wife video records these encounters
and they've really enhanced our sex life
dear god
jay entered our life at about two and a
half years ago it's hard to describe him
but he's pretty much the perfect
bull i don't know what i'm reading i i'm
getting the gist of it i don't like i
don't like the gist that i'm getting
he is handsome well traveled speaks a
half-dozen languages teaches at a
college with a phd
does fitness modeling is well-hung kinky
and the man can literally have
athletic sex all night he is married and
his gorgeous wife is completely
comfortable with his lifestyle
though she does not play play herself
what's more he is completely down to
earth and you never know
he wasn't just a muscle bro unless you
engaged him on some other topic
like foreign policy or persian poetry
it's a joy watching him with my wife or
on video occasionally what's more i
really
enjoy him as a person my wife and i have
two kids and they absolutely adore him
and his wife and constantly ask to go
visit them
okay you know what i'm this actually
goes on much longer than what i just
read there this is like a whole novel
from this guy i don't even know what the
question is
if the question is am i
a deranged disgusting degenerate the
answer is yes i can just give that's a
yes no i just tell you it is right away
i don't need whatever other question
might be i don't need to know what it is
listen this this is not okay no part of
this
is okay no part of this is acceptable
it should literally be illegal if i was
in charge of the country this
you would go to jail for this i don't
want to hear anything about oh it's this
consensual relationship between adults
so some consensual relationships are
completely
effed up for lack of a better phrase and
this is one of them
by the way it's not a victimless crime
there are kids involved
your kids adore your wife's boyfriend is
what you're telling me
yeah well your kids are not going to
adore anything very much when they're
paying thousands of dollars for the rest
of their lives
to a therapist because because you
screwed them up so badly
so i know we're supposed to be open and
have accepting attitudes towards all
lifestyles
i don't at all because some lifestyles
are disordered and wrong and damaging
and toxic and disgusting
like this one so my advice is stop
this what you're doing just stop
everything about it
grow a pair literally preferably your
own pair
all right um so that was sufficiently
traumatizing let's let's read something
else this is from
someone who goes by no splitting the
difference
she writes i'm one of those letter
writers who probably just needs to hear
someone say what i already know
a few months ago i ended a five-year
relationship with someone that i loved
dearly because i couldn't see a way to
agree on a future family
when we talked about kids earlier in the
relationship my perception was that both
of us were pretty ambivalent
now it seems clear that becoming a dad
someday is important to him meanwhile my
ambivalence has drifted toward being
child free
if baby fever hasn't hit me yet it's
just not going to right
everyone told me i changed my mind when
i was older but now i'm 32 and i still
don't see the appeal of having kids
the stress of wondering whether we have
a future together was really affecting
me so i called it off
at the same time he's my best friend i
love him with all my heart it's hard to
imagine ever having that with someone
else
did i do the right thing is there any
middle path for this for us that i don't
see
and how were we able to misunderstand
each other for so long all right
so your problem with this guy you love
this guy uh he's your best friend
and your problem with him is that he's
responsible and wants to have a family
that was the deal breaker most people
aren't gonna tell you this
uh or or won't put it to you like this
but the fact is that the reason you
don't
see the appeal of having kids is that
you're selfish that's the reason i mean
that really is the reason we could try
to dress it up all we want and say oh
there are other reasons why
no that's 99.9 of the time someone who's
an adult doesn't especially in their 30s
doesn't want to have kids still it's
just because they're selfish they're
pathologically selfish that's the reason
almost always
you know you like your freedom quote
unquote you don't want to you don't want
some
anything tying you down you want to be
able to spend money on vacations and
that sort of thing and
that's why you don't want to have kids
well the problem and what you have to
realize is that
a life lived only to serve yourself is
not fulfilling it can be distracting
though
right if your life is fundamentally
empty because you only focus on yourself
then the good thing is that you have
time and money to distract yourself and
so you can take all the vacations and
buy all the fancy stuff
um the problem is that eventually life
slows down
maybe not yet for you but it does
eventually and the distraction
techniques don't work and now you're
left alone
with the emptiness and at that point
when that happens your options are
limited
you know when people say you'll regret
it when you're older they don't mean 32
okay they mean like 52 and at that point
it's too late
to have kids what will happen is you
will regret it
because you will be alone and old and
you will die alone
and when you finally do die no one's
going to care because you don't have
anyone around to even grieve your loss
good news is you're only 32. you can
still change courses maybe go find that
guy who was you love so much and super
responsible
and uh and wants to be a father maybe go
find him maybe go get him back
here's another one it says wife spent
life savings
that's the headline okay i'm married
with four little kids i work
uh my wife stays home she has struggled
with anxiety and depression for which
she is on medication
we're pretty easygoing except for one
big rift in our marriage credit cards
i'm against them and don't have one my
wife has always been financially smart
as often takes care
of the bills in our home we agreed that
she would use her credit card smartly
and paid off every month
she did not like me seeing her card
statements
part of her anxiety is feeling judgment
when there is none i agreed and it was
never a problem
so we stopped looking at the statements
however in the last three months she has
spent our entire life savings in
online purchases i'm devastated well my
wife is really smart with money
except when she's blowing all of her
money on amazon purchases but
except for that part of it she's really
smart i'm devastated i had put a little
money aside every month for various
projects and vehicle upgrades and it's
all gone
the question actually goes on from there
but it's it's cut off because you have
to subscribe to slate to read the rest
of it
unfortunately i don't care enough about
this guy's problem to pay a monthly
fee to read it but i think i got enough
of the idea of it what i'll say is this
first of all
if your spouse doesn't want you to look
at a credit card statement
that is like a red flag with sirens and
warning lights going off
and big just blinking lights saying
problem problem the only time
when it's maybe okay for your spouse to
tell you
not to look at the statement is around a
gift-giving occasion
and they're saying oh i just bought you
a gift i don't want you to see it on the
statement so can you not look at it for
the next week or something but this is
not one of those times
in fact if there's anything your spouse
doesn't
want you to see credit card text
facebook message internet search history
anything
i mean anything if your spouse is trying
to block you from seeing
anything that means with rare exception
they're doing something horrible
and or at least thinking about it they
don't want you to know
so when your spouse says i don't want
you to see this and you get that if you
get like a sinking feeling like that
something's wrong here
well something is wrong i mean something
really horrible is probably happening
that's just the reality this doesn't
mean we should have no privacy as
married people
it just means that we shouldn't be
hiding things that's that's the balance
you have privacy you get your own space
if you're making the effort to hide
something though
now we've got a problem all of this to
say how in the hell did she manage to
blow through your whole life savings
over the course of three months and you
didn't notice
you want to look at the credit card
saving statement and she said oh it
makes me it gives me anxiety when you
look please don't look at it
oh it gives you anxiety when i look at
the credit card statement that's all the
more reason to look at it bring it here
now i need to see it
so i guess you were afraid of coming off
as patriarchal or something if you spoke
up so you didn't say anything and now
you're broke this is what happens
and guess what you're the one who works
and earns the paycheck
so your wife has lost your credit card
privileges
that's the consequence when you plunge
your family into destitution because you
want to buy stuff from amazon
take the credit cards you give her a
monthly allowance
like a child you don't want to have to
do this but
you're not working every day to support
your wife's amazon shopping sprees are
you
so she did that to herself and you did
it you're both a fault all right finally
um
from someone signed do i give him a
timeout
says how do i approach a seven and a
half year old boy who makes
sexist jabs at me some context
i am his 23 year old cis female cousin
and i've been watching him full time
since august i adore him but i loathe to
tolerate another
yeah but you can't use a drill because
you're a girl comment
my current approach has been cool
puzzlement hmm why would you think that
followed up with i can see why you would
think that but there aren't such things
as boy and girl things and it hurts my
feelings when you tell me
i can't do something because i'm a girl
and then maybe some follow-up discussion
about how making that kind of boy girl
distinction can hurt our friends
it's not getting through though i think
part of the issue is that i'm working
from home and i'm currently embodying
traditionally feminine roles like
caregiving
plus he is probably getting counter
messaging at home i love him but these
jabs are really hitting me in the soft
spot and honestly
i know these kinds of thoughts are
hurting him too how can i better
approach this behavior
let me see if i have this straight
you're getting your feelings hurt
by a seven-year-old boy you're a
grown-ass adult
and your feelings are hurt because a
seven-year-old boy
said only boys use drills
so the question is not how to approach
this behavior
of the child the question is how to
approach your own behavior
specifically the behavior of being
fragile as hell
so what i would recommend here is get
over it
i mean he's a kid and actually there's
nothing wrong at all with
with children associating certain
activities with boys and girls
you know you know why uh the supposedly
sexist seven-year-old is doing
that you know why he associates like
using power tools
with boys because he has eyes
and a brain unlike yourself apparently
and he can see that most of the time
when someone is using a power tool
it's a boy just that's just what it is
he sees that and so he draws these
connections absolutely nothing wrong
with that
he is drawing reasonable connections and
associations between things
that should be encouraged not dissuaded
so you need to get over it
the boy is fine and uh that's all there
is to it should we do one more
no i don't think we should i can only
stomach so much basically to summarize
my advice to everyone who seeks it from
slate
um i guess just to just to get get to
the to the upshot get to the point it's
um
stop being horrible and stupid